Well, good afternoon, everyone. Welcome to those that are here in
person and also to those that are online.
I'm delighted to facilitate this very timely forum,
focused on cell therapy at a crossroads, exploring the evolving
landscape between autologous, allogeneic, and in vivo
engineering.
So I'm Christine Brown from City of Hope.
I'm a professor and the deputy director of the CAR T-cell
program at our institution. And in addition, my research
program focuses on developing, optimizing, and
translating CAR T-cells for brain tumors and other
solid tumors. And thus far, my work is really
focused on autologous cell therapy, which I'll be speaking on today.
It's really a true pleasure to be able to chair this session with
my co-panelists here, that will provide expertise in
their respective areas of cellular immunotherapy.
So, it's a true pleasure to have Zachary Roberts
to provide perspectives on allogeneic cell therapy. Dr.
Roberts is chief medical officer at Allogene, and
he's a well-established clinical oncologist who spent
over a decade developing cell therapies.
Previously at Kite, he played a key role in the development of,
and commercial launch of axicabtagene ciloleucel.
He authored and ran the ZUMA-6 trial and helped advance programs
in multiple myeloma and myeloid malignancies.
He also worked on tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes for solid tumors
and now leads research and development at Allogene,
advancing allogeneic cell therapy approaches.
We also have Dr.
Alberto Diaco on the panel to provide the latest
thinking around in vivo engineering of CAR T-cells.
Dr. Diaco is director at Tessera Therapeutics,
where he leads efforts to develop RNA gene writer
technologies and apply them to in vivo engineering of CAR
T-cells. Prior to Tessera, he worked at Bluebird Bio,
working to advance lentiviral vector design, manufacturing,
and safety for gene therapies. So, the format today is
that each of the panelists will give a brief
presentation, followed by a panel discussion.
So I really encourage interaction, questions, discussion.
This is really meant to be an interactive discussion.
We're late in the afternoon, right before dinner and cocktail hour, so
hopefully that will promote people participating
and asking questions.
The forum today, I think, is very timely.
The field is entering this new phase focused on
improving scalability, accessibility, and
broader clinical impact. And I think the recent news
yesterday of Lilly's acquisition of Kolonia for its in
vivo engineering platform signals a clear direction to the
field for simplifying manufacturing and increasing
patient access. So with that, I'd like to get started.
I have the following disclosures, but for this presentation, I will touch on a
collaboration that I'm working with Solaris on for
autologous manufacturing.
So where are we now when it comes to T-cell
therapy? So it's clear that these autologous
cell therapies have had tremendous impact in
cancer. And so while most of the approved therapies,
or all of the approved therapies to date, really take
cells from the patient themselves or a related donor and expand them ex
vivo prior to adoptive transfer back
into the patient.
We know that in order to address access questions and
others, we need to think about new approaches.
So to date, there's nine FDA-approved therapies, and all
of them use autologous manufacturing.
Seven of these are CAR T-cell products targeting CD19 or
BCMA, and then we also have two products in
solid tumors that were recently approved: Adaptimmune's
TCR product targeting Mesothelin-CG4
for sarcoma and Iovance's TIL product for
melanoma. And so this really just represents the
beginning. If you look at the late-stage pipeline,
patient demand is really growing, and it really highlights
some of the challenges that we're going to see in trying to make
these therapies more accessible to more patients.
So not only are we getting new therapies in cancer, but also
expanding into autoimmune diseases.
And so all of these, four out of the five, are
also using autologous manufacturing approaches.
But there's one allogeneic product that's in pivotal
phase two testing that my panelist will talk about
today, Dr. Roberts.
And just to emphasize this point more, I went to
clinicaltrials.gov, did a search for CAR T-cell therapy.
This is spanning
all autologous, allogeneic, and in vivo, but
there's over 2,700 clinical trials
listed on clinicaltrials.gov, really spanning
hematological malignancies, solid tumors, and autoimmune
diseases. So how are we going to address this access
challenge, and how are we really going to
show that this therapy can innovate and fulfill its
potential? And so it really leads to questions I think that we'll address
in this forum. So how do we scale manufacturing
and increase access without compromising potency,
consistency, and safety?And most
importantly, also, how do we reduce costs and
shorten that time of delivering these products to patients
and expand real-world patient access?
I think there's questions as we think about next
generation engineering approaches that we
think will probably be required for solid tumor immunotherapy
and which platforms are best suited for this.
And also, I think that we should consider where might each of these
manufacturing models, autologous, off-the-shelf, or in
vivo, really fit clinically. And so I hope that we'll be
touching on all of these sort of questions throughout this
forum.
So today we'll have three talks. I'll also be speaking on autologous cell
therapy.
Zach Roberts will speak on allogeneic cell therapy, and
Alberto Diaco will speak on
in vivo cell engineering. And so my
experience with autologous cell manufacturing has really
been from an academic perspective.
At City of Hope, we have over 16 active
phase one trials. We've treated 500 patients.
We manufacture anywhere between 55 to 85
patient products a year. And I think what's been important in this
experience is the autologous setting that's really allowed us to
iterate and innovate. And so, we've tested
over 12 CAR T cell platforms for manufacturing
processes. We've been able to engineer virus-specific T
cells. We've been able to test CRISPR knockout CAR T
cells and look at combination therapies.
And so I think this is great, and I think it talks about some of the
advantages of autologous therapy.
Still today, it remains the best
platform of testing true therapeutic potency and
safety in first-in-human trials.
And it really does allow for this rapid innovation and
iteration. But I think critically are the challenges that we
need to acknowledge. These are very labor-intensive and
costly products. This one batch per patient
limits scalability and access, and even the
T cells that you isolate from the patient can have variable
quality, particularly for heavily pre-treated
patients.
Ex vivo culture can limit
the fitness of these cells. The therapy
requires prior lymphodepletion, which for more fragile or
older patients can be a limitation, and it really
lengthens the delay in getting these therapies to patients.
And so there's been a lot of innovations in the autologous setting of
how to address some of these challenges.
So I want to go through some of these.
And the first is the move towards more rapid
manufacturing processes. So this has been really critical to the
field. So we've known for a long time, the longer you grow these
cells ex vivo, the more differentiated and
exhausted they become, and the greater the cost and the lower the
throughput. So what's been great to see is that groups have been
moving from these conventional seven to
14-day manufacturing processes where it takes
about a month to get the product to the patient from
leukapheresis to administration, down to these
rapid manufacturing processes of just under one to three days,
where these products can now be delivered in closer to a
two-week timeframe to the patient.
Obviously, much more clinically friendly.
So I really think moving towards this rapid
manufacturing process has significant
advantages for autologous therapy, not only
improving potency, lowering cost, but also
getting these therapies, these products to patients more
rapidly. And so we see a transition
in many of these clinical trials. There's many platforms that have been
developed. I won't go through the details of them, Fast
T-CAR, Nex-T, T-Charge, DASH, but
really moving the manufacturing not from two weeks, but
one to five days, and I really look forward to further
seeing the clinical outcomes of these and what it will
achieve for improving access and
reducing costs. Another big area of
innovation for autologous or just ex vivo manufacturing,
so allogeneic or autologous, has been this move
towards automation. So we now have many
systems that are looking to fully automate the
expansion, and even gene engineering
processes. This includes the Miltenyi Prodigy system,
the Lonza Cocoon, the Ori Biotech Airo,
and the Solaris Cell Shuttle.
And so obviously these have tremendous
advantages, reducing the hands-on labor,
improving process consistency, shortening these
workflows, and when it's automated, it doesn't matter if you're working
at night or the weekend. The Cocoon or the Cell
Shuttle keeps going. So we believe that these
automated systems are really going to allow us to increase
scalability and reducecosts and may
also facilitate the possibility of more
decentralized point-of-care
manufacturing. And so I've been excited to collaborate
with Solaris in some of our GBM-targeted CARs,
and so we've moved forward with a collaboration to work with
Solaris to get our GBM manufacturing
process for a pooled CAR approach.
Really thinking for solid tumors, we need to have
polyclonal targeting.
And so we're actually combining different CARs based
on the understanding of the antigen landscape of the
tumor. And so we were really excited to work with Solaris
because not only do they have their cell shuttle system really
to automate manufacturing, but this manufacturing
platform is very flexible, allows for cell selection, allows
for electroporation, gene engineering, and also
allows for
simultaneous dual product manufacturing, and
also integrates automated QC. So
we talk a lot about manufacturing, but the time for QC
is also critical, and so being able to automate QC we see as
having significant advantages. And Solaris has
obviously treated patients with their platform that's been
manufactured on the cell shuttle, and they have FDA
AMT, Advanced Manufacturing Technology designation,
which makes it attractive. So I'd like to just end by
talking about thoughts around distribution
of these therapies. So right now in the US, we really have a
centralized manufacturing
model where
hospitals ship leukapheresis products to a centralized
manufacturing facility, where the product is manufactured and
then shipped back for treatment. And these obviously have
advantages just for
standardizing a know-how and rigor
where these
cells are being manufactured, but it does
increase the length of time to get these products to patients.
It does increase costs and cause some logistical
complexity. So there's been an idea of possibilities
of moving some of the autologous cell manufacturing
to a local point of care. And so this, you could
imagine where the manufacturing takes place
at the site of treatment or nearby, and it
really can accelerate how quickly we can get these
products to patients and reduce costs.
But obviously, the big concern here is product
consistency and
know-how at each site. But it's been nice to see
that several countries have shown that
point-of-care CAR T-cell delivery does
work and is feasible, and it's exciting to see the work
going on in Spain and Mexico, really, and others, really
showing the feasibility of this decentralized approach to
autologous cell manufacturing.
So with that, I'd like to just end with sort of
perspectives on the autologous cell therapy and for the
other presentations. I think autologous
T-cell therapy remains the most clinically validated
platform to date, and I look forward in the next
five or less years, really seeing how
these other approaches, allogeneic, in vivo, really
transform our field.
The future success for all of these platforms will rely not
only on safety and efficacy, but really scalability, speed,
cost, and access. And I think you'll hear from the other panelists
the opportunities there for both allogeneic and in vivo.
With respect to autologous manufacturing,
the idea of being able to manufacture these cells more
rapidly with automated platforms and
even more
flexible regulatory frameworks, I think will be key
enablers. And so,
we'll see where the field goes. I think what will be interesting
is really how these approaches complement each
other in distinct disease settings.
And so with this, I'd like to pass off the
baton to my colleague and panelist,
Zachary Roberts, to talk about allogeneic
cell therapy. Thank you very much.
Thanks very much, Dr. Brown, and thanks everybody for carving out a bit of time
here towards the end of the conference.
They clearly saved the best for last.
Okay, so I'm going to dive into allogeneic cell therapy. As Dr.
Brown pointed out, there is clearly a growing need for
a variety of new indications coming online for allogeneic
cell therapy or for cell therapy in general.
And we believe that
having an allogeneic platform is going to be critical to achieving that
demand.
But before we get there, of course, there are clear
requirements for any new modality coming online, such as allogeneic
cell therapy, that it has to be an improvement over what's already available.
And so I think of these as really the foundational benefits as
what is required in an aspirational way for a
new platform like allogeneic cell therapy
manufacturingTo replace the proven efficacy and safety
that Dr. Brown highlighted with the autologous product.
So first of all, they have to be useful.
They have to provide some clinical utility, and really focusing here on efficacy.
There has to be a durable response in whichever disease we're talking
about with the one-time administration that is afforded by the
autologous products, and we have to start the therapy with the intent
to cure. We can't be eroding the efficacy signal by
moving from an autologous platform to an allogeneic one.
We have to improve the patient accessibility.
So not only does this mean
a more immediately available product for infusion when the patient
needs it, without the need for leukapheresis and manufacturing,
but also it has to be safe. It has to be something that can be administered
not just in
well-connected, well-run academic centers with a bunch of experience in an
autologous, but really, how do we get outside of the
academic centers and into the community where, as it applies to cancer,
80% of patients with cancer are managed fully in the community setting
and really they don't have access to autologous CAR T.
So can we improve access with a new platform like
allogeneic?
And then finally, of course, we have to be able to do this at scale.
At Allogene, our current manufacturing would enable us to produce 30,000 to
60,000 doses of cell therapies per year.
The range there is dependent on which cells, which product we're
using, and what the cell dose is. The cost of goods manufactured in
this context is as little as under 10,000 per dose and
up to 20, again, depending on the product.
Ideally, this would be used and ordered using a simplified
mechanism through an EHR, without
approaching this like a procedure such as a bone marrow transplant.
And of course, it would need broad payer acceptance and utilization in health
systems.
But before we get to any of those aspirational statements, we really need to talk
about some basic immunobiology. I'll be speaking
mostly today about allogeneic CAR T cells, but of course, there are other
manufacturing platforms as well.
But it all boils down to can we do this safe and efficaciously?
And really that begins with graft versus host disease and the opposite, host
versus graft. Do these allogeneic healthy donor-derived products
recognize the recipient as foreign, causing GvHD?
Or
does the immune-attacked recipient recognize the
incoming CAR T cells as foreign and reject them before they can render
their efficacy?
So depending on, you have to forgive me for the
joke here about chassis, but I couldn't pass up the opportunity to make a
CAR T joke, but depending on which cell therapy platform
you use, you have different pros and cons.
So with NK cells, and Dr. Rezvani gave a wonderful talk just a few hours ago about
all the work she's doing at MD Anderson on NK cells.
She's absolutely correct. They have the
off-the-shelf benefit of having little to no GvHD
risk. They're easy to manufacture.
However, their short persistence requires armoring and
sometimes repeat dosing. They also have native tumor targeting
abilities, so you get two for one with the CAR plus the endogenous
native tumor targeting capabilities.
The same applies to gamma delta T cells.
They have intrinsic tumor targeting capabilities.
However, they're extremely rare in the peripheral blood, which makes their
manufacturing very difficult.
And then finally, on the right-hand side, iPSC derived T or
NK cells, often sometimes regarded as the holy grail of
allogeneic cell therapy because you get large doses of master cell
banks, you can make thousands of doses of cells from those banks, so you get
manufacturing consistency and scale.
However, as the cartoon illustrates, this can be quite lengthy and complex
manufacturing.
So today I'm going to be focusing on CAR T cells, and the story begins about 10
years ago with one of the very first examples of
using healthy donor-derived mature T cells as a
CAR T manufacturing substrate, and these investigators in England
introduced a fairly garden variety CAR construct here
with a CD19 targeting moiety and then a 4-1BB co-stimulatory domain.
They also did some gene editing to make these CARs safe by
eliminating TCR expression through disruption of the TRAC locus with TALEN
gene editing, and they also disrupted the CD52 locus, which you'll
see is a recurring theme in my talk.
The manufacturing process was fairly straightforward, shown in the middle, and on
the right-hand side, these are the cells that come out of the end of that
manufacturing process. High CAR positivity, low TCR
expression, though not zero, which is what that upper red box on the right-hand
side is meant to convey here. And then also a substantial
fraction of these cells being CD52 negative.
So they treated two infants with this construct, and they found that
they were largely safe, and the first baby that was treated with the
refractory B-ALL did have some GvHD, which
was attributed to that residual TCR positive
CD52 negative population I pointed out on the previous slide,
that required them to treat with first topical steroids, then actually
trigger the kill switch, which is included in this construct, and then take this
infant to a second allograft, shown here as allo
SCT2.
They were quite encouraged, and I think reasonably so, by the efficacy as
illustrated in the MRD assessment in this baby,
who cleared their MRD by day 28. So
obviously a great proof of concept here that these cells manufactured from
healthy donors can bring efficacy
with some manageable safety
with that skin GvHD.However, when
they looked at the expansion kinetics of
these infused cells,
they realized that there was a whole future of work on
host versus graft to be done. So on the first
patient that was treated, as shown on the left, with fairly limited CAR
T expansion. There was some persistence out to that second allograft.
However, we didn't see the typical large expansion within the
days following that we had seen with axicel and lysocel by this
point. The second infant that was treated, who similarly had a great
clinical outcome, they increased the dose of
cytotoxic chemotherapy, which corresponded to a much larger
initial burst of CAR T-cell expansion in vivo.
However, these were rapidly cleared from circulation.
So, with these first two patients, we realized that we had a persistence
issue that we needed to surmount.
At Allogene, we have taken this CD52 concept and really run with it.
The idea behind it is once you've knocked CD52 out of your CAR
T-cell, as we've done in our lead program here, celma-cel,
administration of a CD52 monoclonal antibody would
create a preferential impact,
whereby the host T-cells would be eliminated through the
CD52 monoclonal, whereas the CAR T-cells would be spared, opening
a window of persistence. And indeed, in our Phase 1 experience in large
B-cell lymphoma, we found that patients with the highest exposure to
alo-647, which is our alemtuzumab-like molecule,
had the best CAR T-cell expansion and persistence as assessed by AUC28.
And conversely, those with the lowest exposure to the CD52 had
the lowest, AUC28.
This idea of deepening lymphodepletion to improve allo CAR T
expansion persistence has been done by others as well, even
without the CD52. And so here is an example of a peer
company of ours, Caribou, with a CB-011
product for myeloma. They've enhanced the engineering a little
bit to cloak these cells by eliminating beta-2 microglobulin,
thereby eliminating class I expression, and they've replaced it with
a transgenic HLA-E to prevent NK-mediated
elimination. But even with those cloaking additions to this
product, you can clearly see a differential on expansion
when you go from 300 milligrams per meter squared of Cytoxan to 500.
So again, suggesting that the depth of lymphodepletion of these allo recipients
impacts the CAR T-cell persistence.
In our hands, in relapse refractory LBCL, the
CD52 plus FC regimen has worked quite
well. Here is a safety from a fairly extensive Phase
1 program that was published last year in JCO, showing good tolerability, which
is emblematic of allogeneic cell products.
No high-grade CRS or ICANS. I'll highlight here, no GVHD.
And by the way, we've treated over 200 patients across multiple programs,
and with the TCR editing that I highlighted, we have
not seen a case of confirmed GVHD. That seemed to have been isolated to that first
patient treated that I highlighted a moment ago.
Efficacy-wise, again, thinking about those must-haves that I
highlighted at the beginning of the talk, we saw good efficacy with this
product, I would say comparable to what we see with autologous CAR
T in a similar patient population with a 67% overall
response rate in the Phase 2 regimen.
Almost all of those responses were complete with good durability and
overall survival.
Other approaches to enhancing persistence and expansion of allo CAR T
are doubling down on the complex engineering to further cloak and
enhance the performance of the cells.
So eliminating Class I, as I pointed out, is being
done widely, but you can also eliminate Class II.
You can also disrupt genes that induce exhaustion of the CAR T-cell, such
as PD-1. This strategy has been undertaken by
a group in China, and they've treated three autoimmune
patients with this complex engineered product,
and they've seen significantly improved
expansion and persistence in these patients going out now several months.
So what I'll talk about now, though, is reframing how we think about expansion and
persistence with allo CAR T. And
I think of this really as an in vivo effector-to-target
experiment. And really what we want to do is optimize that ratio.
Instead of just driving the highest expansion and the longest
persistence, which itself brings both acute and chronic toxicities,
if we can tailor the expansion to the clinical scenario, that might be a better
way to go about doing that. And
so what do I mean by that? Well, first, talking about
what we know about disease burden and response and toxicity in
CAR T-cells, we've known for some time, and the patients who have low
disease burden at the time of their CAR T-cell infusion tend to do better from both
an efficacy and a safety perspective.
And this is, on the left, is data from axicel that was published a
few years ago, showing that the greater your baseline
tumor burden, the less likely you are to have a durable response and the
more likely you are to have a high-grade neurotoxicity event.
And in our hands, in this Phase 1 experience, we also saw in a subgroup analysis
that patients with low disease burden at the time of celma-cel infusion did
much better, as assessed by normal baseline LDH
or low disease burden as assessed by CT, in which we saw an
82% or 100% complete remission rate,
respectively.So how do we take this observation and layer it
onto a clinical trial? And so coming back to LBCL,
we have treated LBCL patients the same way for about 25 years.
At diagnosis, almost everybody gets R-CHOP or some variant
thereof. And about 90% of the patients who are treated in this way
achieve a remission. Most of those tend to be complete remissions.
The small minority of patients who have a
primary progressive disease after frontline treatment go straight onto
salvage. But after these 90% of
patients achieve a remission, we essentially embark upon a
surveillance program where we watch and wait for the disease to recur.
And after several years, if your lymphoma hasn't come back, we declare you
cured, and off you go.
However, there are about a third of these patients who, during
that period of follow-up, will actually experience a disease recurrence.
And under the current treatment paradigm, we don't really know who is who.
However, in the last several years, there's been quite a lot of work done on
minimal residual disease, both in LBCL and of course beyond.
And the data that's on the screen right now is data from one of our
collaborators, Foresight Diagnostics, who was recently acquired by Natera,
who is developing an ultrasensitive ctDNA-based
MRD test. And when this test is performed at the end of frontline
treatment,
we can really parse these patients out into two groups, those who are likely to be
cured, that's the blue line. These are folks who are
ctDNA undetectable at the end of frontline treatment.
And those who have residual disease but are in a clinical remission, are very
likely to experience disease progression, usually within the first six to 12
months.
We can also quantify the disease carefully using these tests.
And what we've found is that there's about a 200-fold lower disease
burden at the end of therapy in an MRD positive patient as compared
to the disease burden at diagnosis or at the time
of relapse. So really what we are able to do with this MRD
test is zero in on those patients with the lowest imaginable disease burden.
In my effector-to-target ratio construct, these are the patients with the
lowest target burden that we can think of.
So we saw an opportunity to run a clinical trial here, which we have started.
It's called ALPHA III. This is just those patients I just described,
patients who are in remission, but are MRD positive at the end of treatment.
And we're randomizing these patients to either observation, which is the current
standard of care, or a dose of consolidation cemasil.
EFS is the primary endpoint of this trial.
Secondary endpoints are shown on the bottom right.
The target enrollment is 220 patients.
We're currently open in about 60 centers here in North America and
recently just activating sites in the Asia-Pacific region.
As luck would have it, we just
last week performed this very first interim
look at the data that we call a futility analysis, which I'll take you through now.
We examined MRD clearance. So as a reminder, all these patients are MRD positive
coming into the study. But we assessed whether a
dose of consolidation cemasil would eradicate that
MRD in these patients. So what we found that in almost 60% of the patients who
were randomized into the cemasil arm,
emerged MRD negative as compared to 16.7% in the
observation arm. And this change in ctDNA happened very quickly.
So the first time we looked after these patients are randomized is at day 45.
And at that time, we saw a median decrease of about 98% of
the circulating tumor DNA in the patients who received cemasil versus a
26.6% increase in the patients who were observed, which is, of course,
what we would expect if we leave these MRD positive patients alone.
As interesting about as the efficacy is the safety, and
again, thinking about this E to T ratio concept.
We saw no cases of CRS. We saw no cases of ICANS.
No tocilizumab or steroids were given to any of these patients.
Of course, no GVHD.
Infections were balanced in the two arms.
We did see slightly more
other neurologic events that were largely attributed to the FC regimen that
the patients in the cemasil arm got.
And importantly, none of these patients were admitted to the hospital for
management of side effects. And as I come back to
those aspirational themes at the beginning of the talk,
can we get this out of academic centers and into the community?
A third of the patients who were treated with cemasil were treated in community
oncology practices, many of which have never given a single dose of CAR T
before.
So getting this access out of academia and into the community where
80% of these patients are treated is a major strategic imperative of any
allogeneic platform.
In the last few minutes, I'm going to shift gears and talk about another way to
achieve optimal E to T.
In the case of the RCC program, renal cell carcinoma, the target
ratio or the target burden in these patients is quite a bit higher.
These are metastatic solid tumor patients.
And the theme of this last few slides
is more about a good offense being the best
defense in terms of allogeneic rejection.
And so I'll be talking a little bit about the CD70 biology we call the dagger,
and we've incorporated this dagger of technology into our next
generation platform, which is ALO329, which we're developing for
autoimmunity.So early on, we discovered that
not all CD70-targeting CARs were created equal.
CD70 is a very interesting target.
Not only is it expressed highly in RCC and other solid tumors and heme
malignancies, but it's also an activation marker for T cells, and it's
upregulated when a T cell engages its target, be that
an allogeneic CAR T cell or an
infectious particle or what have you.
And so that sets up a little bit of a problem.
So as you're manufacturing CD70 CAR T cells, the CD70 CAR
expressed on the T cell will recognize the CD70 on
neighboring CAR T cells, inducing something that we call fratricide.
However, if we design the
CAR T cell to target membrane-distal epitopes in the CD70,
we can actually establish what we've called cis-masking, where the CAR will
actually block the CD70 on the CAR T cell, thus
preventing neighboring CAR T cells from engaging the CD70 on
that CAR. And on the right-hand side, you can see
a difference between Class I CARs,
which target membrane-distal epitopes, versus Class II CARs,
which target membrane-proximal
epitopes. And in a flow cytometry experiment, the
CAR T
will actually block the detection reagent from
sensing the CD70 on these cells, thus illustrating
this idea of cis-masking.
So can the CD70 CAR prevent allo rejection, which is, of course, one of the things
that we hope it will do? The experiment on the left-hand side shows that, in fact,
it does. So when you use alloreactive host T cells
and a CAR T cell, and you mix them together in a mixed
lymphocyte reaction, non-transduced CAR T cells will
stimulate an allo reaction, and you'll see the host T cells
upregulate CD70. Again, we expect this.
However, in the presence of a CD70 CAR, those
CD70-expressing fraction of host T cells are eliminated,
and this leads to robust expansion and long-term survival
of the CD70 CARs in a mixed lymphocyte reaction.
This has been validated now in the clinic in the renal cell
carcinoma program with a longstanding Phase 1
trial called Traverse. And we have selected a
Phase 2 regimen of 80 million CAR T cells following standard
lymphodepletion, so no ALO-647 or CD52 monoclonal antibody
here. And in patients with high CD70 expression, we saw
31% durable overall response rate with kinetics
that are consistent with what we expect of cell therapy, with rapid reduction
in tumor burden by day 28 and durable remissions.
But really what's interesting here is this validation of this dagger technology,
and that the expansion and persistence of this ALO316, as shown on the table on
the right, was really quite unprecedented, both at the level of Cmax
as well as the AUC28,
outpacing what we see with approved autologous products in hematologic
malignancies. And this is really driven by this allo reaction
by the host T cells. And this slide illustrates that further.
First, on the left, we see great expansion, really quite unprecedented
levels of expansion just in terms of magnitude, more in responders than in
non-responders as we would expect.
But in patients who have follow-up within the study, we're able to find CAR T
cells readily in the periphery out to nine months and beyond.
So really, we see longstanding persistence here.
But what's even more astounding is that when we deintensified the lymphodepletion
regimen here by removing ALO-647, we saw
improved ALO316 expansion in the days following
infusion. And this really, I think,
summarizes very nicely that the magnitude of the allo
response to the incoming CAR T cells serves as fuel to the
allogeneic CAR T cells and in the
rejection avoidance schema. My last data slide is here, and this
is to illustrate that we can take this dagger effect, the CD70 CAR, and
actually pair it with other targeting moieties, such as
CD19 CAR, as we're doing in our autoimmune program.
And what we've done in this experiment is model
allo rejection in a mouse. And so we've
simulated lymphodepletion by either giving a
low dose of healthy donor PBMCs to these NSG mice or
a very high dose, as if these mice had not been lymphodepleted,
100-fold more
potentially alloreactive healthy donor PBMCs.
We then infuse the CAR T cells, and then we monitor for persistence at day seven
and 14. And in the right-hand side, what we see is sort of what
we'd expect for the CD19 CAR, and that in the absence of
lymphodepletion, we see very little persistence of the CD19 CAR, which is,
of course, improved when we
simulate lymphodepletion. But we see the opposite in the
context of a dagger-endowed CAR, in that when we leave out
the lymphodepletion in this experiment, we see a 10 to 20-fold better
expansion of the ALO329 as compared to when we pair
it with a lymphodepleted mouse. So really
paradoxical observation here showing that this
dagger technology can really propel the expansion and persistence
of these CAR T cells in the context of an allo response.
So to conclude, the early safety concerns from allogeneic
CAR T cells really focused on GBHD have largely
been addressed by effective gene editing
of the TRAC locus.
We are now showing, I think, clear evidence of
efficacy in both heme malignancy and in solid tumors.
We can further improve upon this efficacy and safety through novel clinical trial
design as well as next-generation product design and really
targeting the optimal in vivo E to T ratio.
And finally, if we're successful in the clinical trials that we have ongoing here
and with other sponsors, the manufacturing scale and the cost of
goods will represent a breakthrough in access to this technology for
patients.So with that, I'll thank the patients and the investigators who have been
with us on this journey for a long time.
Of course, the Allogene Therapeutics team, many of whom are in the audience
today, thanks for all the hard work in solving some of these problems.
And to our peer companies who are carrying this baton along with us.
Thank you.
Thank you very much for such a fantastic talk and really
great data. So that's wonderful. So we're going to move to in
vivo gene editing, the hot topic of this
session, with Dr. Alberto Diaco. So thank
you for presenting.
Thank you to Dr. Brown and Dr. Roberts for sharing
the progresses in the autologous and allogeneic
CAR T cell therapy. And I'll now share with
you,
I will talk about in vivo CAR T engineering, and I will also share with you a new
technology that we developed at Tessera to approach
the in vivo CAR T using RNA to generate permanent
insertion of CARs.
This is my disclosure slide.
I don't think I need to cover any further how
transformative ex vivo autologous, ex vivo CAR T cell therapy
has been for hematological malignancies.
But there are still some challenges that are being addressed,
but they still
pose some challenges. For example, the
patient eligibility that
is slowed down by the long manufacturing timelines and
the conditioning of the patient, the limiting patient
access to the facilities, to center and hospitals,
and also the expensive and complex manufacturing of the product.
I believe in vivo CAR T has the potential to overcome these
limitations.
So when we talk about in vivo CAR T, we're talking about reprogramming the T cells
directly into the patient.
In the autologous CAR T therapy, we need
to collect cells from patient, and as Dr.
Brown showed us before, the cells needs to be handled outside of the
patient, and the cell needs to be transduced with vectors
and then reinfused into the patient after conditioning.
In the context of in vivo CAR T, you just need to have
a vector that works at delivering specifically to T cells.
So you just inject your vector in the patient, and the vector will find
a T cell inside the patient to generate and engineer the CAR
T cell.
Here I'm highlighting four
requirements that I believe are very important for a successful in vivo
CAR T, especially in oncology. The first one is the targeting
specificity, where we need to have a selective delivery to T
cells.
This is
less of a problem in the ex vivo setting, as you have a limited
number of cells that you are transducing or you're transfecting,
making it less challenging, as
you have less off-target cells available in your pool of cells.
Once you go in vivo, you have potentially every cell of the body that could be
targeted by your
vector. Therefore, you need a good
specificity of the vector for your T cells.
The second bucket is engineering efficiency.
Of course, we need sufficient efficiency in order to achieve therapeutic
activity.
In vivo CAR T is quite novel still, so it's
still hard to say how much efficacy you actually need in the
body of a patient in order to achieve
a therapeutic activity.
But what I can say on this is that at least there is a benefit of
going in vivo, and the benefit is that
you're not only targeting the T cells that are present in the
circulating blood, but that you have a much bigger pool of T
cells that you can actually target once you go in vivo, as you can also target
different tissues and different
organs.
Concerning safety,
we have
a similar
outcome that we need to control compared to ex vivo CAR T, which is
what happen once the CAR T cells encounter the
target cell, the tumor, in this case,
and the following
immunogenicity of the activation of the T cells.
But we also have
an earlier
potential mechanism of toxicity of this drug
product, which is at the delivery time.
We are injecting in a patient something that is foreign, that
the immune system of the patient can recognize, so we'll need to
be able to control well the toxicity of the drug at
injection.
And second, we'll need also to minimize genomic perturbation.
As we know in the CAR T space,
people talk about the insertional mutagenesis, insertional
oncogenesis, which seems to be less of a concern compared to
the gene therapy in hematopoietic stem cells, for example, but it's still
something that needs to be carefully scrutinized.
And last, durability of response, which is
essential for
achieving a therapeutic activity especially in
oncology space.
So now I want to outline the different approaches that they
are clinically advancing in the in vivo CAR T
space. And these are the RNA in
complex with LNP and lentiviral vectorSo in the
case of mRNA delivered by LNPs, we're talking
about a non-viral approach that is designed to
enable transient CAR expression without a genomic integration.
That comes with the benefit that you don't have to be concerned about
the insertional oncogenesis, for example, as there's no event of insertion.
But it has the drawback of a limited durability
that may be solved with repeated dosing.
But still, it's still something that needs to be further explored in
order to obtain durability with transient CAR.
And so far, I just want to underline that the clinical programs that are advancing
with the transient CAR are mainly focusing on autoimmune
diseases, and this is probably also because of the biology of the disease,
where autoimmune diseases, the patient needs to
have a complete
depletion of the B cells to have a reset, which the bar, it seems
to be lower compared to a tumor where you need to reach
the tumor cells in area of the body that are
harder to reach, and therefore you need a more durable
treatment.
That's where lentiviral vector comes in.
They are viral vector-based approaches, and they
are associated with stable genomic integration, and they show
a pattern of integration that is biased towards genes.
The beauty of the integration is that it leads to a durable CAR
expression that will last for a long time.
And
as I was pointing out before, the durability then becomes an
advantage in the oncology programs.
Therefore, we actually see way more programs that
are using lentiviral vector in the oncology space.
A final point I want to make is that we start seeing now some
initial clinical studies, and we are also seeing
some acute inflammatory toxicities that will
definitely need to be addressed and
resolved.
So now I'll shift gear, and I'll start talking about
our technology that we developed at Tessera, which we call
GeneWriters. This is an RNA-based approach that is intended for
durable CAR expression, and is based on the biology of
non-LTR retrotransposons.
So what we did, we engineered
a non-LTR retrotransposon, and we got to this
engineering platform that is composed of these two RNA molecules,
a template RNA that contains the sequence that encodes
for the therapeutic genes, in this case, the CAR, and a
GeneWriter mRNA that encodes for the gene editing protein,
the protein that allows the insertion in the genome.
These two RNA molecule can be packaged in a
targeted LNP, and upon
delivery in the T cell,
the RNP complex will
reach the insertion site and will
trigger a target prime reverse transcription, which is the
mechanism of replication of non-LTR retrotransposons and will allow
the integration of the CAR in the genome.
I just want to show you a
subset of these GeneWriters that we identified. This is just one slide.
There's a lot of work behind the discovery and the engineering of the
GeneWriters.
We screened a lot of them, and this is just
five of the
GeneWriters that show activity in human T cells.
And in this experiment, I'm showing nucleofection of the two RNA
components of the five different GeneWriters.
And the template RNA is encoding for a GFP reporter.
Therefore, we monitor GFP percentage to look at
the activity of our GeneWriter. As you see, we have variability
between writers that goes between 25% to
3 to 4%.
But I should also say these are the elements that came out of our screening.
These elements went through more rounds of optimization and activity
was improved even further.
One last point I want to make about the technology is that
interestingly, we found that the GeneWriter
have an integration pattern that resemble a
random distribution. It doesn't have a gene-biased integration
as we know it happens with lentiviral vectors.
And so what I'm showing you here is a unidirectional sequencing
experiment to look for integration sites.
And on the right plot, you see the distribution of the integration site
across four different genomic features:
intron, exon, transcriptional start site, and intergenic
sequences. Intergenic sequences are the sequence that they are distant
from genes. And as you see, lentiviral vector don't have a lot of
insertion around intergenic sequences, while GeneWriter
seem to have a distribution that is actually very close to the random
distribution that you see in the first bar.
Internally at Tessera, we also developed our proprietary delivery
platform with the LNPs.
And in order to do that, we have been screening ionizable lipids,
targeting strategies, and formulation in order to achieve
cell type specific tropism,
good delivery efficiency, and good
biodistribution.So now I'll show you how
we have been using our gene writers
delivered as an LNP.
In this case, in vitro. We are starting showing you the in vitro results
when using a CD19 CAR template.
And here I'm comparing transfection with our LNPs
to lentiviral vector transduction in PBMCs.
And what you see is that we are achieving a
comparable percent CAR-positive cells, comparable
CAR-positive T cells,
and that these T cells actually show comparable tumor-killing
activity when doing a standard tumor-killing
experiment using different effector to target cell
ratios.
So now I'll move to
the use of these gene writers in vivo, and I'm going to show you two
different murine models. The first one is a tumor model
where we took
NSG mice with MAC Class 1, Class 2 knockout.
We engrafted tumor cells. We infused human
PBMCs, and then one day after, injected our
LNPs containing the RNA for the gene writer.
We then evaluated the CAR T positive
percentage and the tumor burden over time.
So as you see in the left plot,
we are achieving around 25% to 30% CAR-positive T cells
at peak of expansion around day 13.
And at that time, this coincided also with the complete
elimination of the tumor burden in the mouse model
compared to our vehicle control, where the tumor
continues expanding over time.
In the second model, we are using now a CD20 CAR, and we are
targeting a humanized mouse model, which is an
NSG mouse that has been engrafted with human hematopoietic
stem cells. We infused the mice with our targeted
LNPs, and we evaluated CAR T%
presence
in the peripheral blood and the presence also of B cells.
Why B cells? As we are using a CD20 CAR, and
CD20 is a receptor present in B cells,
we can use it as a
readout to assess the killing
activity of our CAR cells.
So in the left plot, you see how at three different
doses, starting from 0.3 MPK down to 0.03
MPK, we were able to achieve, with the two highest dose, around
20% CAR-positive T cells that led
to a relatively fast B-cell depletion exactly at the time of
expansion of the T cells. But we also have a very
low dose, a 0.03, where we still see activity of the writer.
We are seeing a delayed formation of CAR-positive T
cells with a
lower expansion compared to the two higher doses.
But we do see also a corresponding delayed
B-cell depletion, meaning that even at a 0.03
concentration, which is a very low LNP concentration, we are able to
achieve
B-cell aplasia in this mouse model.
So I just want to close,
putting in perspective the three technologies now and
focusing on the gene writer. I wanted to show you this
novel non-viral approach that
is able to enable genomic integration,
but without showing a gene-biased insertion
profile as we are seeing with lentiviral vectors.
And in conclusion, I think the beauty of the gene writer is that it
can enable durable expression without the use and the need
of a viral vector.
And in conclusion, I just want to thank all the people at Tessera
that have been contributing to the work, and thank you all.
Thank you, Alberto, for such a great talk, and
really exciting seeing the gene writer technology move forward.
A lot of possibilities.
Thank you.
Now we'll open it up for discussion, and happy
to take any questions, comments,
thoughts as we move towards
the panel part of this discussion.
So if you could go to the microphone and then-
Hello. Over here.
Yeah, great.
Great talk, guys. Thank you so much for everything.
There's been a lot of
clinical data coming from the MD Anderson group, showing that the COVID
vaccine, the mRNA-based vaccine works by
awakening through an MDA5 and an
interferon alpha-induced mechanism
to improve checkpoint blockade in lung cancer
patients.
Do you think that the patients that have gotten in vivo
CAR T through either lentiviral
vectors or through an LNP that have an
mRNA that's inflammatory would
help or hurt the development of
anti-tumor immunity?
I'll take that one.
Yes.
I think it won't help because I think it won't be possible to deliver a highly
immunogenic
RNA systemically in a patient. You would just get a systemic response
to the RNA, and
this is actually a problem that people in the RNA
field are trying to solve. And most people use
N1-methylpseudouridine modification on purpose so that they are able to
avoid the
immune response in the patient. And there is a concern
that unmodified RNA, which is the one that would trigger an innate
immune response, would just trigger a systemic response
and therefore lead to even lethality in the patient.
Thank you. I guess it's the dosing issue and the response that one can expect
from the copy numbers that we're using for creating in
vivo CARs that's very different from an mRNA vaccine.
Exactly. And also, we're talking about systemic injection versus
intramuscular, and so
with the vaccine, you actually want to promote
the inflammation to favor the effect of the vaccine.
While in this case, you really don't want to have inflammation because that would
be lethal.
Thank you so much.
We can go to the other side and
be fair to both-
Thank you
... sides of the room.
It's nice to put all this together.
So I have question for Robert. So I
really like the design for ARFAS-003
clinical trial, and thank you for sharing the exciting data.
So I'm wondering
if you have checked
cell expression
correlate with either MRD clearance
or ctDNA reduction.
Yeah. So the correlatives will be shared when
we read this study out. We're collecting all that information,
and I, for one, am very eager to see what that expansion
profile looks like,
because I frankly don't expect it to look like the,
for example, the axicell expansion and persistence profile looks like.
We know with this
light lymphodepleting regimen that we're using without the
alo-647 CD52 monoclonal antibody, that these cells
will be rapidly eliminated from the immunocompetent
host. And we actually see that as beneficial because it
allows restoration of B-cell
immunity in these patients more rapidly.
So we'll have to wait to see what those data look like,
but certainly, I'm expecting potentially a paradigm shift
as we're thinking about treating patients with MRD-only disease as opposed to
treating patients with very bulky tumors.
Great.
Thank you for the talks, all of you.
For the GeneWriter
platform vector technology, and you may have mentioned it and I missed it, but what
were the size limitations for the insert that you're putting
into this?
Right now, we are
getting up to a CAR the size of a CAR with the promoter.
We didn't really define the limit of
size of
the transgene that we can have as a payload.
But the CAR with the promoter can easily be fitted.
I guess that's the
question. For these in vivo CAR T products
for solid tumors, I think you're going to need more complex
engineering, but if you can put 20 or 30
KB into a cell with an in vivo technology, that's
a game changer.
What we think we can do is we can actually insert
multiple transgene, but with multiple
template in the genome, so different template in the genome.
So that is something we think we could do.
The versatility of this system is that you just need a template with
these unique sequences that will be recognized by
the gene editing machinery. And then in theory, as
long as you can encapsulate in an LNP multiple RNAs, you could bring
in
the machinery for multiple insertion of different CARs with
one LNP formulation.
So a really great set of talks. My question actually comes out of
that one, which is for the in vivo editing, there's so much literature on
how different T cell subsets like T stem cell memory
cells and so on are better than others.
So in vivo, do you anticipate finding novel cell surface
markers to target specific T cell subsets and also
T cells on different locations in the body?
Peripheral versus in tissue, how do you reach different T cell subsets in
vivo?
Yeah, I think this is a great point.
There's a lot of unknown once we go in vivo, right?
Because we don't really know
all the cells that we can target. We don't know we could really change the
paradigm of CAR T.
At this point, it's hard to predict,
so we need really to see how the field moves
forward. There's a potential to be able to
treat
diseases that maybe with the ex vivo, it's not possible.
But again, this is a possibility. We don't know until we move forward in the
field. But it is a great point, that you're going to be able to
deliver your
material, your CAR, to cells that maybe
by taking only the peripheral blood cells, you are not going to be
able to do.
It's a possibility.
Thank you.
Okay.
Okay, so
following up on the previous question about possible use of
multiple constructs.
You could simply use a red and green fluorescent
protein and see if they get together in the same cell.
My question is more about did you monitor the
occurrence of inefficient integration of
partial pieces of DNA,
respect to the 20%, 30% that you get,
and the issue of insertional mutagenesis?
You're talking about-- Sorry, I didn't get the first part.
Is-
Right, sir
... truncation?
The first part is a simple way to check, which could be you just put two
construct, one encoding red and the other green fluorescent-
Yeah
... see if they both get in the same cell.
Yeah, we
do that. In vitro, we did that. We can do that.
But considering instead the clinical application,
this is not guided like in the case of lentiviral LTRs
So you can have just pieces of the DNA that get
integrated, and so the 20% that you see could actually
be much more integration events. Many of
them are in efektyashches, but they could drive insertion on
mutagenesis.
So the biology of the retrotransposon is that we know they
integrate from the three prime end to the five prime end, and so they
do get truncated sometimes. That is part of the biology
of the retrotransposons. So when we generate CAR T
in vivo, you're going to have a
natural selection for only the one that contain the full length
CAR and promoter. Otherwise, you won't be able to expand the
population and target the CAR. In vitro, we
do see truncated products. We did
do a full characterization. We can do
a simple copy number assessment like you do for
lentiviral vector, but
putting your primer probes on the three prime end so that you
can target as many copy as possible.
We analyzed at the
single cell level how many times you may end up even having
extremely small deletion, and this is something that doesn't really happen.
So we think with our assay, with our current
ddPCR assay that we are using for detection of insertion, we are actually
detecting most of the copies, so we can tell how many copies
per cell we have.
We cannot give a clear picture
of
the full integrity of each single copy we have, but I think the
benefit is once you go in vivo, it's really that you're getting a selection, a
clonal selection for the one that actually have the full length copy.
Thank you.
Okay. Over here for the question.
I also have a question about the Gene Writer technology.
I
didn't study enough, probably, but I think the random
integration strategy, wouldn't it have the risk of
integrating to an important gene, affecting T cell biology
and have the potential to have specific
clones that could be
detrimental to the body? And why don't you choose
a strategy that integrate to a specific site that you know it is
safe to T cells or to the body?
That's absolutely a great point, but that's a goldmine right now, trying to find a
way to target it in a site-specific manner.
We haven't been able to do that yet.
The beauty of the system is that it's a very simple system, so we can engineer
it, and we are trying to retarget it to specific places.
So the answer to your first question is yes, it's possible that we
insert our payload in essential genes.
But I guess the argument in favor of the writer
is that we
don't have a bias like lentiviral vector, therefore, at least we have less
chances of inserting inside an essential gene,
as lentiviral vector and HIV insert specifically
in
highly active genes. So in a way,
the random distribution has a bit of a
favorable
pattern of integration.
Okay. And what are the sizes of the two MRAs that are
in the LMPs?
We are around
two to three KBs.
Oh, okay. And
are they encapsuling to the same LMPs or in-
Yes
... two different LMPs and then mixed together?
Or formulated, yes.
Sorry?
Or formulated in the same LMP.
Got it. Thank you.
Yeah. Hi. Thanks a lot. Beautiful talks.
I have a question for the allogeneic cell therapy.
Despite you doing so much gene engineering and you need a
high cell dose, how long is the expansion ex
vivo of the T cells to get enough doses for such
a trial?
So similar to what is
often achieved with the NK cell manufacturing,
we get about 100 or so doses, give or take, per
manufacturing run with the lentiviral-based
manufacturing platform that we're using for the alpha three semi-cell
program.
It does take a little longer to achieve that
magnitude of expansion, but we're talking about a few days difference here.
Of course, the obvious benefit is that all of this is done off
of the critical path as it pertains to the patient.
We can manufacture these products months or even years in advance
of needing to use them in the clinic, so it decouples
the duration of manufacturing from the
clinical need.
I was more wondering about the efficacy of the T cells because it is shown now
in many studies that the shorter the ex vivo culture is, the
more potent the T cells are.
So yeah, I think that has been shown
in most scenarios. I think that
story is still being written. I think there's some very
interesting data that's been published in recent years
illustrating that there are subsets of T effector cells
that are actually doing a lot of the initial killing in the immediate post-infusion
context, and the durable persistence may in fact be
related to naive and central memory subsets.
But in the sort of days and week to two weeks
after infusion, I think we don't quite know who's doing the heavy
lifting on that. So again, coming back to how I think
about the utility of an allogeneic product, even one
that may be more
differentiated during manufacturing than others, is can you
eradicate the target cells within that first
windowAnd achieve the desired clinical outcome, even
if you are administering a product that may be somewhat less
naive in central memory or stem-like than one that took five days to
manufacture.
Yeah. Okay. So I see that for sure for the MRD and low disease burden
for solid cancers might be a different case.
Well, I showed you the data from the relapse refractory program
as well. We saw great durability there in a significant fraction of those
patients. So I don't think it's
necessarily a black and white situation.
You can still get good efficacy.
We're giving 120 million cells flat dose, so
we're seeing pound for pound reasonable
efficacy with this product.
Thanks.
So I'm going to move to an online question for Zach.
So in the MRD setting, is expansion a challenge
due to the small target pool and therefore minimal activation
of the CAR T? So how does the MRD setting
impact the expansion of the allo product?
So the short answer to that question is you get the expansion that you need.
At least that's what we hope, and I think that's what the early look at the
data from Alpha-3 illustrated. That we
expect to get less expansion in an MRD only context, as opposed to a
patient who's got kilograms of tumor.
And we actually see that as a feature, not a bug.
Because it therefore promotes a
much more accessible safety profile
with fully outpatient dosing and so forth.
So, it's a great question, but the idea is to match the expansion
to the need.
Thank you.
Thank you. Really great talks. Maybe this is more of an opinion from any of
the three panelists. Looking at all across the three technologies,
do you foresee as the technologies progresses,
there are certain disease biologies that we would choose one of these
technologies over the other? Or do you see potentially one
winning out due to cost, productivity, and so on?
So I think that's a great question for all panelists,
right? So are we seeing an evolution of approaches or
really are there clinical settings that are best suited for each
approach? And
maybe I'll start off with the autologous cell
platforms, and then we'll move down the line to the newer
sort of technologies. But
one of my focus areas
are brain tumors. And
so the autologous setting has been very well suited for
that and delivering these cells into the brain.
And the safety was an important aspect of having an
autologous product and knowing we could give those local regionally.
Now, it would be very attractive to have an allo
product that was ready to go in the setting of CNS
malignancies, because often these patients can't wait.
But
I think multiple individuals have presented at meetings, and
we have seen this as well, the brain is
not immune privileged. We still see
immune rejection, and so that becomes a
significant consideration. And so,
the question is, even when we give local regional delivery, which we
really focus on in the brain, will you need to lymphodeplete in an
allo setting?
I'm very interested to see Alberto's feedback in brain tumors.
Could we give in vivo and still get these
cells to traffic in the brain? So that to me isn't quite as
clear, but that might be one disease setting that might be better suited to
one or two of the approaches and maybe not the first
indication that in vivo might want to tackle.
Maybe that might be later, but I'd be interested because we have MRD
negative settings or MRD positive
settings and
cancer autoimmunity and others. So I'd be interested in the other
panelists' feedback.
I do believe there's going to be differences
in the way how the ex vivo versus in vivo, let's
say,
will play differently in different diseases.
So I think there will be some space for one type of application and some
space for the other type of application,
where I think your example is a perfect example where we don't know if in vivo
will be able to
even reach the
brain and being able to modify the T cells and
have an effect there. While for in vivo, what we
are seeing an advantage, I think, at this point, if
it's going to be confirmed that
autoimmune disease are really going to be
the CAR T is the solution for autoimmune diseases, then
I do think transient mRNA could have a strong advantage
over most of the other approaches.
Even in vivo lenti, I think it would still have
a drawback in terms just of safety, because the transient approach,
it just has
a softer touch on the patient, which these are patients that
already
are extremely sick, so the
less of an impact on the patient you have, I think the better would be.
So I think that's an example that could go in favor of a specific technology.
But I do think there will be
a variability between the different
diseases and the different technologies that will be used.
And I'll add that allogeneic, I think, is going to have a role
to play.
I highlighted one example with Alpha-3 in the MRD context when you need a
rapid, easily accessible product that you can administer before a patient
progresses.One could envision potentially an in
vivo
approach working in this context.
However,
many of these patients are going to be so lymphopenic coming off of six cycles of
R-CHOP or dose-adjusted R-EPOCH that there's not
enough endogenous substrate to
transduce with your in vivo CAR T product that you're not
going to get the efficacy. So having a fresh batch of incoming allo
CAR T cells to do the work is going to be important.
So that's an example where I think having a ready-made
120 million or whatever the dose may be, ready to go,
is going to be quite helpful.
Thank you for the question.
Along those same lines, there's an online question
really emphasizing as the world is moving to in
vivo, is there still a role for autologous TAC,
especially for brain tumor ICV administration?
And I think we sort of touched on this.
One, I think there's an important role in a lot of these first in-human
applications, and you still see pivotal trials moving forward
in the autologous setting. But as these new approaches show
utility, I think there's a lot of benefit.
But I think in certain disease settings, such as brain tumors with ICV
delivery,
I think autologous is going to continue to play a key role, and
I think we're sort of reiterating some of the other themes to that.
But hopefully, we addressed that question.
I do have one more question online,
and then we can sort of wrap up with final
thoughts.
Do you foresee the applicability of the CD70 CAR
dagger in the allo products regardless of the target and
indication? Or do you believe the risks of that compound
require a case-by-case decision on whether to include it
in the product design? I think the dagger data was very
intriguing to many. So getting your thoughts on that, Zach.
Yeah, that's a great question, and I'll have to start by saying I
don't really know the answer to that question.
I can offer a few thoughts. So one of the intriguing
things of the CD70 construct is that
it allows us, as I illustrated in the RCC program, to reduce the
intensity of the lymphodepletion, which has long been part and parcel of
CAR T. And so in the context of the autoimmune set of indications,
where, of course, we're pushing the dagger forward in the dual
CAR construct,
we're actually leveraging that intrinsic lymphodepleting
element of the dagger
and reducing the intensity of the lymphodepletion that we're giving the patients in
that phase one program. So we're giving Cy only or giving
no LD at all to see if whether we can rely entirely
on the intrinsic
expansion relying on the dagger. So
to address the question, I think there's a give and a take for
each one of these cases. If inclusion of the dagger allows us
to reduce exposure to cytotoxic chemotherapy, I think that's a
good thing.
If, on the other hand, we end up with
an overexuberant expansion and persistence that is inappropriate for the
target indication that we're treating,
that's a problem. And so I think we'll have to do this, start out with a
case-by-case look at this and
pick out some indications where the risk tolerance is sufficiently high that we
have a little room to maneuver and then go from there.
But I think it's a very exciting technology that has lots of potential.
Absolutely.
So with that, I think we will wrap up this
forum. Very much appreciate those that are here in person
and that joined us online on the penultimate day of this
conference late in the afternoon.
But thank you for your participation.
Thank you to my co-panelists. I think these are important and
evolving topics that we will continue to discuss, and we will
see the importance, I think, of all three
technologies really impacting patient care.
Thank you very much.